welcome back to koi's comic corner i am so excited
to be here thank you thank you thank you for the
response to this show please like subscribe
leave a comment this episode was actually a
fan suggestion of what to talk about they said
they wanted to know more about doctor doom and
here we are and remember if you want to know
more bite-sized comic tidbits check out my
tic toc i'm making all of these all the time
15 seconds to three minutes or even a minute
there's lots of stuff over there but in the
meantime here long-ish form where i can rant
let's talk about doctor doom because doctor doom
seems to be the source of a lot of conversation
lately so we're going to talk about why he's so
popular right now how i think he's going to be
introduced and why i don't think that's
in fantastic four gonna talk about some
fan casting ideas the ones i hear rumbling and
other ones that i personally think would be rad
why i think that there are certain comics that
are going to influence it but not as directly
because i think the mcu is going to take him
in very different directions and most of all
what makes dr doom one of if not the best
marvel villain of all time let's get into it
dr doom is the talk of the town doctor doom is
everywhere because we haven't had doctor doom
we've had the fantastic four rumblings we've had
john krasinski show up in multiverse of madness
and the character i think a lot of people want to
see most post thanos is doctor doom i think right
now we've got kang as the big underlying villain
i think he's our big emperor palpatine for phase
four and i think all these story lines are gonna
culminate in kang but i think right alongside
kang just as it is in the comics we're gonna have
doctor doom currently in the comic books there's a
like a quantum entanglement between kang and
doctor doom in the current solo title of doom
kang appears and is tethered to doom and i don't
think that is a coincidence for where the mcu is
going oftentimes there are hints at what the
movies are doing in the comic books and right
now that is a very big storyline so first of all
who is doctor he is a badass evil dictator that
runs latveria and basically latveria is what
i think they were going to try to make sokovia
but they didn't have the rights to doctor doom yet
when you think about the sokovia accords when you
think about a lot of the scenes not in new york
in the mcu there are people that are under tyranny
and doctor doom's interesting because his people
love him but he abuses them he's one of our first
very very important political figures in the mcu
and the reason i don't think you introduce him
in fantastic four is because you want the time to
do him justice you want him to feel like someone
bigger than just one corner of the mcu when you
meet him just like we met thanos in a post credit
scene for the avengers you don't want it to feel
like oh this is going to be a captain america bad
guy if you introduce him in fantastic four you're
already introducing four brand new characters to
some people or reintroducing them and improving
upon them plus you're gonna have to establish
why they haven't been here all along and try
to establish why he is or isn't john krasinski
depending on how things go you're going to be
doing a lot in that movie with tone with story
with all those things so if you haven't seen my
fantastic four episode of koi's comic corner i
mentioned annihilus i think annihilus is a very
streamlined villain you get the big boss fight
out of the way but you also build the science
and all those things within the fantastic four
doom needs to be introduced i believe in black
panther too black panther 2 is already going to
be bringing in a lot of political intrigue you've
already got a passing of the torch from one black
panther to another you've already got the first
character that we're gonna see unfortunately in
a very sad way lose where we left off with the
last film and i think that passing the mantle
is gonna be very brutal but i think they're gonna
hand that in a very political way i think there's
going to be an election i think there's going
to be a lot of discussion of what the mantle
means and i don't think it's a coincidence
that namor seems to be in that movie namor
is another almost elected official he's the king
of atlantis he's also a very arrogant leader that
butts heads often with doctor doom i personally
would do the less jokey version of the illuminati
by having a bit of a round table of leaders that
kind of help run the world it would make sense to
introduce our new black panther along with neymor
as a villain and then have doctor doom there
running things behind the scenes and also as
someone that the wakandans are aware of i think we
need to start sprinkling in latveria and the more
global scale of these movies as we introduce more
global characters you may notice that the mcu as
it is right now is not as based in new york city
things bad happen in more than just new york city
and the characters need to start reflecting that
so i think while they're doing that doom needs to
be doomed there needs to be a sense of foreboding
there needs to be a sense of otherness and so much
going on so i think we're going to see him as soon
as potentially black panther 2. whether he's in
the movie or in a post-credits scene how insane
would a post-credit scene be they somehow keep
this under wraps and then doom just like clinches
a fist with the mask like i could see them doing
that with this character i also think as i said a
second ago introducing him in the movie not
only puts him in one vein but also we don't
have the time to really embrace victor von doom
now victor von doom is a man who is as tech savvy
as reed richards who is as intelligent as reed
richards but he also has mysticism on top of that
so imagine someone with the political power of
black panther the tech savvy of reed richards or
if you don't know reed that well perhaps iron man
picture an iron man black panther combo but he's
also got doctor strange thrown in there this dude
is terrifying because he's all of those things but
he will destroy you like that and will and often
has done that with heroes and civilians alike
the only thing he cares about is his kingdom
the only thing he cares about is his ego and
the character is fascinating because when he was
first introduced the way that kirby envisioned him
was someone that was so arrogant so narcissistic
that he wore a mask that had a tiny scratch in
his face and that tiny imperfection kept him from
the perfection of others that little tiny thing
made him feel like he had to do all of this
and then later john byrne one of my favorite
artists one of my favorite writers great guy
decided to make it more of a mangled totally
disheveled more traditional phantom of the opera
situation where like depending on the continuity
you're reading homeboy's face is all messed up
either way his arrogance his ego his narcissism
fuels everything he does maliciously
he's afraid to show his face personally
i would love if he becomes doom scratchy boy and
you see that level of insanity on a beautiful face
all my casting choices which we'll get to later
and some blokes but i think through the course of
maybe the sequel or as things evolve maybe then
you go full jarnburn his face gets all messed
up maybe it's something reed does he often blames
reed and there's a beautiful parallel between the
ben grimm thing and dr doom as far as things that
happened to them that made the monsters as caused
by reed richards so this is a guy who's got all
sorts of tech he's got doombots that rival ultrons
he's got mysticism that rivals doctor strange's
and there's a really fun dynamic with his mother
where in a comic book i'm going to get to in a
bit he and doctor strange actually team up to
save his witch mother and that leads to his whole
bloodline and that leads to the ancestry so you
could also incorporate agatha harkness so if this
goes like i want it to and they introduce him as
soon as black panther 2 we could potentially seen
flashbacks in agatha harkness we could see all of
this relate to maybe even helping scarlet witch
build up her magic back or if she's gone he helped
build that whole scarlet witch tower there's so
much that doom relates to that i feel like we
need to start establishing them as a bigger bad
that takes over the whole universe as ever i want
to give you some of my casting ideas uh some of
these have been floating around some of these are
my own i personally want someone that's vaguely
european which is a weird thing to say but there's
a there's a nest to latveria that i really want
them to capture i would love if doom has an accent
i would love if he feels not like a guy could run
into in a burger king and i really really really
love the actor rufus sewell and i feel like that
dude does not get enough credit he is the knight
in a night's tale the evil knight he's also got
this high castle show on amazon he has this really
really piercing gaze that makes you feel like
[__] like he's so so condescending with a glare
and he's the nicest guy in the world like rufus
is a great guy but the way he looks at you is
doom he's also got a very commanding voice i need
to feel like i'm this big when i see doom looking
through that at me doom is death embodied so you
need to feel like death is staring you in the eye
so the actor's eyes are very important so you feel
the depth of doom of death my next pick would be
michael shannon homeboy is a force of nature there
is almost no one that when you're in a room with
them you're both like i want you to love me and
i'm also scared shitless this guy could lead an
entire community this guy could run a country of
latveria so i want someone that is both charming
in his own way not to charm you into liking him
but to charm you into fearing him and that to me
is michael shannon plus he's built like a brick
[__] house dude's giant then i've got goron
vishnik this dude is from the er days he showed
up in the boys he's the cult leader from the boys
cult leader is actually a perfect example of why
he's one of my picks he commands you with a glance
and he makes you doubt your own reality when
you lead a cult you've got to be so captivating
and so capable of getting people to follow you
that you don't know why exactly you're shedding
your family and your choices and all these things
and i think goron has always been that actor and
he hasn't really had the time to fight into a role
of this size and i think he'd do an exceptional
job then one of the ones that's been floated
around for quite some time that i totally agree
with definitely has that european nest i could see
him win the doom mask and i've never seen him play
a full-on villain viggo mortensen i think viggo
mortensen post aragorn has been doing all these
great smaller roles like captain fantastic and
popping up and things i would love to see him go
the other way and be terrifying i love him as
a great dad i love him as a leader i love him
as the guy you're rooting for i want to fear him
but i want to see him as doom and i think he has
the presence he has the eyes he has the gays he
has the leadership give me that doom and my final
one for you is maybe the most obvious when you
think about a man flipping a coin doom doesn't
do that when you think about a guy that's gonna
scare you shitless with just a can of air also
not do think about javier bardem as dr doom think
about his drolling speech pattern his ability to
make spaces and words that aren't there that make
you go like tell me more but i'm scared i want dr
doom to be someone that pulls you in while you're
running away and very few villains in cinema have
done that quite like anton trigger's haircut
and javier bardem under it give me javier bardem
as doctor doom now before i get into my comic
recommendations what do you think about dr doom
potentially showing up earlier in black panther
2 before fantastic four why do you think he's so
interesting as a villain and do you want to see
any of my fan casts as dr doom himself let's get
into some comics i got some recommendations for
you guys i think might tie in directly to the
story they tell including doctor strange and
doctor doom triumph and torment this is a very
petite run you can really just absorb a lot of dr
doom in and very few issues and it's dr strange
and dr doom going to save his mother it deals
with witchcraft it deals with mysticism it deals
with the arrogance of doom he's not generally an
anti-hero but at times he's become that and i love
the relationship between these doctors so you can
see why everyone fears him and what that lineage
in witchcraft is and it's also just a gorgeous
run that catches up a lot of doctor doom next
up we've got secret wars 2015. i would firstly
recommend you read the original secret wars the
original secret wars gives you the symbiote saga
with spider-man it's the first time we see the
venom suit it brings in a lot of things i think
are coming in the inevitable secret wars movie
dr doom is also incredible in the original secret
wars but he's more of well like literally there's
a chessboard scene and he's a pawn he's more of
a piece of the puzzle he's not the one running
the board and secret wars 2015 which i think is
going to be a large basis for the inevitable next
avengers movie i think the movie that people
wanted multiverse of madden to be is going to
be secret wars i think that's coming i think it's
going to be gigantic and multiversal it's going
to make end game look quaint but it is largely a
doom story doom when there's an incursion event
which we did get introduced to a multiverse of
madness the idea that these planets collide causes
these shards of planets and the schism of reality
that's an idea that's strongly in secret wars 2015
and what doom does with those is he patches
together the different planets in different worlds
and makes this thing called battle world and
battle world is an entire world he runs much
like latveria and i think if we ever get a giant
crossover event doom and battle world are going to
be integral plus it's beautifully illustrated the
whole story is fascinating it's jonathan hickman
it's illustrated by assad rabies if i remember
correctly and it's just a stunner of a book came
out in 2015 collected and trade pick it up last
recommendation is the current run of doctor doom
he has been around forever he is a jack kirby
stanley creation from i want to say 1962. can't
remember the exact date but i know he's kirby and
lee and he's never had a solo title and right now
i think it started in 2019 we have one that is
so interesting because it is it's illustrated
by salvadoroka so it's almost like a painted
lines even though it's comic book pencils and
coloring it's beautiful and it's basically doom
is blamed for something he warned people about he
warned people that the satellite was going to
malfunction and crashed on earth killing many
people that reed actually helped program and
because he warned people people start blaming
doom they think he sabotaged it they think
he's the one that caused this so doom in his
intelligence is blamed for his arrogance and
he was actually trying to help people so it's a
really fun story of what it means for doom to want
to save people who he is as a man what his morals
are what his line in the sand is with ethics and
basically it allows you to see the different sides
of doom in a very personal story and it ties into
kang which honestly i do think kang and doom are
going to be more integral in the movies than they
are necessarily in the comics so check out doctor
doom it's called doctor doom check out secret
wars 2015 and the original if you have time and
check out doctor strange and doctor doom triumph
and torment those my recommendations those are
my casting choices those are my doctor doom ideas
this has been koi's comic corner i appreciate you
all so much the love i've gotten for this show is
like nothing else remember check out my tick tock
if you want to see more short form comic ideas and
leave a comment below if you've got any ideas for
videos you want to see greg you have anything
to add no no 18 minutes see you soon internet
you